the first season of Westworld has ridden
out of town naked and tied to a horse
but it left us with a ton of questions
and heartache like a farmer's daughter
watching her gunslinger off into the
sunset
first and foremost exactly who's dead
and who's alive that subs died in the
clutches of hosts with white facepaint
is Logan riding double bareback into
eternity was Ford's secret host a
replication of himself to stage his own
death or did Ford actually orchestrate
his own assassination last time we saw
LC she was in a Bernard bot headlock but
we didn't see her die it's entirely
possible that her life was spared by
Ford based on the west-world site and a
crazy trip down the reddit hole if you
follow the White Rabbit there's proof to
suggest that LC is indeed alive William
in black was last seen smiling into the
face of an oncoming horde of fake people
he's been really mean to for 30 years
who happens to be naked and shiny was
Maeve's entire storyline programmed much
too may've surprised Bernard shows her
that she was acting exactly as
programmed when she led the uprising in
the basement levels of the Della's
complex
these are my decisions we never find out
exactly what she's supposed to do what
she's supposed to leave the park or what
she programmed to find her daughter all
along
how many worlds slash parks are there we
know that there are at least two parks
as we saw Maeve's crew of grumpy hosts
moved through the basement of a Shogun
world or samurai world this place but
based on the note that Felix gives Maeve
there may actually be more parks why
would the note read Park one instead of
samurai world unless there were like 20
parks the 1973 film shows three parks
Westworld roam world and medieval world
what does Delos actually want from the
park yes understand the urgency do what
I can Ellis is trying to get information
out of the park
first through Teresa's uplink bunker
where Elsie gets choked then again with
Abernathy turned into a data mule what
that data is and what they want to do
with it exactly is still unknown is the
MIB just using the park to get his
creepy jollies off while his company
steals from itself or is there another
faction at Delos why does Delos hire
such terrible employees Felix was a
great guy but literally the worst
employee ever and the security guards
who couldn't hit anything with their
guns and when they got close they just
yelled cease all motor functions come on
guys why do the hosts have mazes under
their scalps do they all have mazes
under their scalps or just this one dude
who MIB decides to cut up was it put
there just in case Dolores decided to
scalp someone what the hell is happening
how big of a threat is the west-world
host uprising I've got a request for a
pyrotechnic effect fluid it's that easy
huh if the West Road overlords can cause
pyrotechnic effects anywhere in the park
couldn't they just blow the hosts up
where they stand
also other than Maeve all the hosts have
explosives in their spines so couldn't
Delos just start exploding their backs
West world is just one of the shows we
love for more TV nerdiness plus movies
and comics stick with GameSpot universe
and if you want to stay up to date with
all of our TV videos be sure to
subscribe to GameSpot universe on
YouTube it's GameSpot's permanent home
for TV movies and comics as of January
3rd subscribe now so you never miss a
video
you
[Music]